emily has four lemons for every six
oranges right the ratio of lemons to
oranges as a simplified fraction so
there's multiple ways that you can write
a ratio you could write that she has
four lemons let me write that a little
bit neater you could write that she has
four lemons for every four lemons for
every six oranges so that's one way to
write about it
right the ratio of lemons to oranges you
could write that she has the ratio of
lemons to oranges is four to six or and
this is what's going to be most useful
for this problem right over here we can
write it as a fraction we can write we
can say that Emily has four lemons for
lemons for every six oranges for every
six oranges or the ratio of lemons to
oranges lemons to oranges lemons to
oranges is four to six now they want us
to write this as a simplified as a
simplified fraction well it's a fraction
right over here but it's not simplified
both four and six are divisible by two
so let's divide both 4 and 6 by 2 so we
can write this the ratio of lemons to
oranges is 4 to 6 but if we divide the
numerator and the denominator by the
same number which in this case is 2
we're not changing the value we're going
to get 4 divided by 2 is 1 is 1 and 6
divided by 2
sorry that was a boneheaded mistake 4
divided by 2 is 2 4 divided by 2 is 2
and 6 divided by 2 is 3 so you could say
that the ratio of lemons to oranges is 4
to 6 or it is 2 to 3 you could say that
emily has two lemons let me do that in
the same color two lemons two lemons for
every three oranges three oranges that's
not the same color or you could say the
ratio of lemons to oranges for Emily is
2 to 3